donc là on va faire tout le ménage tout
était arrangé là tout était bien classée
la salle de bains oups non qui s'est
éteint la lumière les clichés owen a
beaucoup des jeunes mamans si j'étais
maman pour la 4 août et maman mais t'es
pas capable de ton équipe et tu sors
avec plusieurs garçons pour accoucher
avec tellement de gars sont donc dans ta
vie alors à 18 ans était tombée enceinte
et tu connais même pas le papa salut
c'est juliette et eux c'est alison et
julienne je peux juste le prendre en
photo pour remettre cela pourrait vous
allison pour brut allison à 18 ans et
elle a deux enfants son premier enfant
les hommes elle a eu à 15 ans et son
dernier julian est arrivé quand j'avais
17 ans j'ai l'impression qu'on entend
souvent parler des clichés sur les
jeunes on nous met à l'essai mais loin
de ses clichés pour moi c'est wonder
woman qui fait face à une vie pas simple
avec une super énergie
un jour avant notre rencontre elle a dû
partir de chez sa mère avec son deuxième
enfant depuis un petit moment les
relations des maisons étaient tendues
avec beaucoup de dispute entre mère et
fille et du coup à l'essonne a préféré
déménager dans un logement social
d'urgence en attendant trouver son
propre blog
je verrai chauffer mon le pot de monfils
au micro ondes collective en bas un
petit pot semoule tomates aubergines
hop
oui
mais un moment j'ai retrouvé dans la
chambre mais là on n'est pas du tout
bien
sûr c'est que ça m'embête n'y a pas de
table
et si c'est vraiment camping quoi faut
pas attendre à du luxe quand tu changes
la balle sur le lit où tu dors pas et
puis c'est une douche non tu le met
ainsi dans la douche mais il peut
attraper froid ce qui a pas d'eau ou là
s'il fallait pas donner vos des faits
soit on peut pas boucher le trou et
pourquoi
pas ce que je m'entendais plus avec ma
mère et la mère à enfant elle a voulu
mettre fin m'a mis dehors avec mon fils
de 10 mois donc
j'ai dû partir trouver une solution au
plus vite pour pas dormir dehors avec un
enfant de 10 mois des fois tu es bah
c'est pas toujours tout tout beau tout
rose a des hauts et des bas et des hauts
et des bas mais pour l'instant ça va
bah tu as peur de perdre du temps dans
mary deros et bon temps du tout la chine
c'est bon partir leur président
allison elle avec son copain depuis cinq
ans et c'est le papa de ses deux enfants
pour l'instant vous avez peut-être
remarqué qu'il n'y aucun de ses deux
enfants avec elle mais j'y reviendrais
[ __ ] de la vidéo peu de temps après
son deuxième accouchement socopa se fait
interpeller par la police et condamné à
un an de prison ferme pour vol de
voiture du coup allison se retrouve tout
seul à tout gérer sans âge financière ni
de sa famille ni son copain chaque
semaine elle lui rend visite au parloir
et la pendule un jeu propre et des
petits cadeaux pour les remonter le
moral
alors oui ça fait les affaires papa
alors il ya jack jardinage
nino voilà des cultes mama la lave et
des tee-shirts enfin basique quoi
c'est tout ce qu'il a droit
par semaine je le vois deux fois par
semaine
les parloirs les vêtements à laver a
ramené les mandats afin les envois
d'argent les titres
voilà je travaille en même temps c'est
ça allison elle est animatrice
périscolaire elle s'occupe des jeunes et
des enfants à l'école elle se prend et
fait tout pour créer les bases d'une
famille stade en attendant la sortie de
présente son copain
véhicules heure il est
5h40 du matin on serait pas pour aller
voir beaucoup pas au parloir
et espaces communs en 1h02
ça veut dire combien de temps que je
vienne à paris soit pas à faire un bar
ça fait cinq mois mais il a vu il ya
quinze jours trois semaines puisqu'il
est sorti en permission mais il a vu
vraiment très qui a vraiment car à
bisous et blaye
et là je vois pas pas il faut dire
qu'elle n'a pas on y va go
homme de défis
on va y arriver on y croit
à plat au monde doit regarder mon chéri
tu sa cellule
vip même pas parce qu'il est mûri son
ballon on croit que c'est petit mais à
l'intérieur il est encore des murs
intérieurs donc ils voient pas et que
moi stylisme en jaune ou en rouge on le
voit bien mais du pouvoir nous voir
voilà pas un permis de visite les
identités et livret de famille que j'ai
mon fils avec moi livré famille
donc ça c'est pour vous permettre au
prochain salon voilà ça c'est pour
réserver ben je vais t'aider les mettre
un peu plus tard ce que j'aimais
vraiment au n'a pas d'emploi browning je
savais que valider
quartier un grand s'il vous plaît et
c'est le numéro 2 merci beaucoup
prépare-t-il bout
[Musique]
préval des débats c'est grave je trouve
bien je me sens en fous j'ai vu ma
moitié tu vois
ça ils ont laissé vraiment lorsque le
petit des remèdes ont vraiment
merci d'oulad
matin à l'essonne des poches d'air la
crèche et part travailler mais ce
matin-là elle rend visite à son premier
fils qui a presque trois ans les âmes et
en famille d'accueil depuis un an la
justice a considéré que gérer deux
enfants pour aller c'était beaucoup à
son âge et a vu son contexte familial du
coup toutes les deux semaines allison
des jeunes avec lui pour passer du temps
ensemble et montrer qu'elle en capacité
de le récupérer
tu vas liam son deuxième fils on vous
promet des premiers cas deux ans et demi
qu'on va avoir trois ans qui en famille
d'accueil le plus dur franchement je
suis tellement content de le voir le
plus dur c'est quand il faut pas
normalement et enfin je sais qu'il ya
quinze jours et la pleurer pour partir
de samedi pour aux coiffeurs donc ça va
mais c'est nous voit qu ils parient sur
les grosses crisique on a les bras ils
n'écoutent pas la famille d'accueil
c'est mon envie et ma tout à l'heure
tout y est d'ailleurs
[Musique]
venu le moment
ouais
si tu faire lui wade pas
dû faire ça
oui
résultat les petits poissons
ah oui maman mais le bleu ou noir là
j'écris quoi j'ai crié
papa alors j'ai essayé d'écrire n'ont
pas
voté fin est un peu on dirait ouais
c'est vrai on dirait plutôt m
au
[Musique]
caire alors on est passé à deux heures
deux heures et demie de visite et visite
libre sans personne autour de moi je
peux aller au parfaitement fifa le
magasin et qu'on fiche pas surveiller
donc ça fait graver plaisir et puis là
on attend un logement pour qu'on puisse
les récupérer définitivement qu'après
leur passé entre temps devant juge m'a
quand même fait la petite phrase qui me
fait plaisir oui on espère qu'en 2022
vous allez récupérer votre fils parce
que franchement on voit que vous occupez
bien quoi y'a pas de soucis à nouveau de
là tu te fous de moi là non basketteur
tu va être quoi
je reste qu un jour tu partiras de la
famille peuvent maintenant un jour tu
reviendras chez maman avec julian papa
non oui bah oui ça parce
que papa nouveau bar et tu pas encore
sortir et que tes amis bien sûr bien sûr
c'est pas parce que tu as 18 ans que tu
veux pas s'enrichir avec des copines
soit gelé ça ma mère soit je laisse à sa
tante et bien sûr des fois je sors avec
mes copines si c'est qu'une journée même
si c'est que une soirée plus une nuit
sans ton fils bien sûr que tu peux gérer
la vie de tu peux être jeune maman est
jeune femme aussi en même temps tu peux
gérer les deux
[Applaudissements]
mon amour
comment ça s'est passé avec papa te
raconte liam julian 1 c'était comme un
élève papa et tous étaient trop bien là
pris dans les bras elle a joué oui il a
fait des câlins comme ça il a connu
direct n'aiment pas ils arrivés là c'est
du quatre pattes jusqu'à lui et après il
s'est endormi sur papa tout au long et
puis ils ont laissé une heure quinze de
parloir parce qu'ils savent en lui
disant de laisser quinze minutes de plus
vous savez à quatre fois moins élevé 88
5 heures
pour préparer pour prendre le premier
but à 6 heures pour aller jusqu'à besoin
et puis la
louisiane bien là c'est bien maman bien
la glace était vraiment bien à howard au
kebab ou bisous monfils
[Musique]
coucou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
on est encore jeunes diplômés manque de
câlins bisous l'aï pris son fils aux
saveurs pour six mois qu'il est là bas
ses causes et cueillir que l'impôt
contre six mois
et une heure vite fait en permission
pour sortir du travail minois
hâte d'accoucher quoi
néanmoins c'est priver le 25e temps
entre le 24 et le 25 3 juillet dans un
même temps
il se passe quoi leur attaque j'ai ma
grand-mère à la couche de mon petit de
beurre
bien japonais encore m
merci beaucoup un petit historique ouais
ça va ya un film c'est bon tu te
contentes grave
bon appétit merci
comme la mort
que
d'agrandir ques les grands titres il bat
les bisous à tout à l'heure
trop
la journée d'alison son méga remplie et
encore on n'a même pas tout vu malgré
les clichés qu'on peut entendre sur une
jeune maman à l'essai mené défi elle
travaille et jallet finances de sa
famille cuisine et le ménage s'occupe du
linge pour elle ses fils et son copain
qu'un serré rend visite et son copain en
prison et son enfant placé en famille
d'accueil et fait tout pour montrer
qu'elle est capable de les récupérer
qu'au cherche activement un logement
fait les courses avec un budget
restreint essaye de trouver du temps
pour ses amis et garde constamment la
pêche est un grand sourire sans compter
des heures qu'elle passe dans les
transports en commun du coup tu es
vraiment forte parce que
émotionnellement et financièrement et
moralement à plein de choses qui pèse
sur ses épaules est arriva quand même
garder la pêche car il faut pour le plus
dur c'est
d'être loin de son fils déjà et blanc de
son compagnon qui valent que pour moi
c'est un soutien donc tout ce que j'ai
dans l'ue à évacuer il prend tout mais
c'est dur doit être parrainé paulo où je
peux m'appuyer quoi c'est vrai mon
épaule
mon épaule n'est pas là ma béquille
n'est pas là aussi si je répète mes
enfants alors d'agde actuelle
je sais même pas où serait vraiment je
serais même pas si je vais travailler je
sais même pas si je serai en train de
des cônes et franchement ça m'a changé
parce que avant que j'emprunte de mont
comi j'étais en train de déconner il dit
que justement ça va tout arrêter à
beaujeu les iem c'est ma vie ici mais
amoureux s'aimer mais bon c'est toute ma
vie pour l'instant le futur est
incertain pour alison son but de
déménager le plus rapidement possible de
son logement d'urgence et en novembre
elle espère récupérer son deuxième fils
rien
de compliqué parce que j'ai pas de
logement large dans un hôtel compliqué
car difficile enfin de l'accueil
compliqué aussi parce que je suis loin
de mon cher mais prochainement femme a
évolué et on espère vraiment que que du
positif froid merci d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo j'espère qu'elle vous a plu
si jamais vous avez d'audi de sujet
n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer un message sur
instagram j'essaie de lire tous les
messages même si je ne peux pas répondre
à tout le monde et on se voit la
prochaine vidéo salut